what's the worst thing about living in a
city i wish i could afford the rent
there is a big problem with air
pollution
half the world's population live in them
and by the end of the century it will be
more like 90
over the last 20 years we've been
talking about urbanization is the way
forward but we've seen during covid
people's dynamics and priorities are
really changing so this is a real moment
in time where we have to rethink and
almost get behind a new vision of the
city
ever watch the morning traffic when
people are going to work
mostly it's one car one first
a ton or two of metal that takes up 130
square feet of space more or less
the main issue of cities is that they
are suffering from uh too many cars
so often we design the city with
a view to optimizing the city for
the paid daytime labor market so we
think about how many people can we get
into the city in the morning and out of
the city in the evening rather than
traveling in from the suburbs to the
center to work shop and socialize the
15-minute city takes a different
approach the 15-minute city is a really
simple concept in many ways it's really
just saying that every urban citizen
should be able to meet their basic needs
within a 15-minute walk-off cycle ride
from their house the concept of the
15-minute city was proposed by french
colombian scientist carlos moreno and
aspects of it are starting to be adopted
in cities like paris
barcelona and bogota
it's been described as a return to a
local way of life
new technologies creates a lot of
opportunities to work from home to do
more things in the neighborhood to get
rid of this separation of work and
living
that also would
reduce the pollution that goes with
traffic
the 15-minute city revolves around three
basic principles
the rhythm of the city should follow
people and not cars
each square meter should serve many
different purposes
we should be able to live work and
thrive without needing to commute
before the coveted pandemic the average
uk workers spend 400 days of their lives
commuting
that's enough time to read the entire
harry potter series
159 times
when we foreground infrastructure or we
foreground cars we strip out the thing
that makes the city the city which is
the interaction of people and creation
of culture when we get rid of all those
parked cars in the in the roads and all
the all that traffic we create lots of
space for greening the city with trees
and this also creates lots of
opportunities to meet your friends in
the street my favorite thing about
living in the city the quality of public
space
which encourages you of spending a lot
of time outside and meeting with other
people implementing the 15-minute city
would mean a significant redesign of our
infrastructure
is that feasible
in many cities across the world we've
had kind of 50 years of planning policy
that is about zoning which is about
separating different types of activity
in the city where you would go for
shopping or for work or for home life
and so to be able to make that
kind of pivot into
a 15 minute or localized neighborhood is
a huge stretch for some places the
concept of the 15-minute city also has
its critics
some fear it could get away as poorer
people whose neighborhoods don't have
the jobs and amenities found in more
affluent communities
a lot of places do not have enough
infrastructure especially places where
low-income groups
live and it's a major major wealth and
economic gap there it's clear
that there are different
levels of
liberty and freedom to access public
space depending on all sorts of
categories of identity
including gender but also race also
levels of poverty we have an imbalance
about who gets to shape public spaces
who gets to make those decisions so if
we can democratize that and if we can
open up and have more participation
about what kind of spaces do we want to
live in
then we have more likelihood that our
spaces are going to suit more people
currently we have a very strong decline
of biodiversity partially due to
agriculture practices but also because
of urbanization if we green the city we
create more opportunity for rainwater
infiltrating in the soil that will also
enhance a healthy ecosystem and i think
if we look into the future and the next
generations what do we want to have
those people
experience a rich biodiversity or a poor
biodiversity this is the choice that we
have to make with the 15-minute city
this is
a way to solve this crisis
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video